here's how the survey works you know the
sandy we asked three celebrities to
complete a phrase our first phrase was I
was so sad when they tore down Roseanne
Barr said Mile High Stadium Erin Burnett
said the old Metropolitan Opera House
Larry King said the Tower of Babel
apparently the traffic was I owe my
career to my Edward Norton said acting
coach Christina Aguilera said singing
coach Vin Diesel said mumble coach this
since I was a child I'd been afraid of
Jeff Goldblum said spiders Kristen Bell
said ghosts Bernie Sanders said combs
[Applause]
the dating site I've had the most luck
with is miles teller said tinder Anna
Kendrick said OkCupid former Fox News
CEO Roger Ailes said Fox news.com
[Applause]
it really annoys me when Jack White said
fans get rowdy during a show January
Jones said people don't respect the
environment Mitch McConnell said the
tide goes out while I'm laying my eggs
on the beat
[Applause]
look at him he is a sea turtle nuts from
Kentucky from Kentucky a female yeah
yeah yeah yeah a land from Kentucky yeah
if I hadn't gone into politics I would
probably be Barack Obama said a public
defender Bernie Sanders said the head of
a nonprofit organization Hillary Clinton
said President of the United States
[Applause]
the last thing I do after filming a
movie is Nick Offerman said get a good
stiff drink Reese Witherspoon's said go
celebrate with friends Nicolas Cage said
read the script
[Applause]
oh that's what that was about as a biker
on fire when I need to make small talk I
usually say Anthony Anderson said where
did you grow up
Lisa Kudrow said what are you reading
these days Larry King said where were
you when you heard Ceaser got stabbed
[Applause]
well you sent him the survey said him to
survey that's what he wrote I'm telling
you if he sends his back on stone
tablets I've got a million of these the
hell was that Andy something neural on
Howie Mandel said OCD Glenn Beck said
LDS the Dalai Lama said DTF now
[Applause]
keep it in your robe
you